how do we uh solve this app yeah I think
I I'm not like the kind of guy that's
like cut the head off the thing repeal
the Federal Reserve Act repeal uh Obama
repeal the Patriot Act I would like
those things to be repealed I just feel
like trying to slice it open is just
going to kill everything so like how do
you why do you peacefully I would reject
that premise
I I think that you actually have to
slice it open
and I think that you you've got to go
through the authorized and unauthorized
activities
programmatically and you have to observe
what is the really important stuff and
there is that you know there there are
cyber crime divisions at the FBI that
get people's money back for them when
they're the victims of some Chinese uh
you know phishing attack in their email
and like those people are patriotic
Americans the problem is an increasing
amount of this intelligence gathering
got weaponized politically